the unlv football program won't travel
to fort collins this weekend because of
positive tests with some of the
players sports director chris matthews
shares the latest details and reaction
from school leaders hey chris how you
doing yet thank you very much this is
certainly disappointing news but
not only is this game cancelled over a
dozen college games have been canceled
because of covid concerns unlv was
preparing for that road game to fort
collins
to play the rams but concerns began to
mount when some rebel players tested
positive so the game was scrubbed
here's what unlv athletic director
desiree reid francois said in a
statement this afternoon
based on four positive cobit 19 results
in our football program
the resulting contact tracing and
consulting with our
medical experts unlv will not travel
this weekend for its scheduled game
at colorado state coach marcus arroyo
also released a statement we are very
disappointed to not be playing csu this
weekend
but understand the circumstances the
health and safety of our players and
staff remains our top priority
and we are proud of the lengths everyone
has gone through to play football
in 2020. unlv's next scheduled game is a
home game at allegiant stadium against
wyoming and
hey speaker the cowboys it was announced
today that their game with utah state
also canceled and will not be made up